i want to pull up this story here we
have about bill maher from the daily
wire bill maher rips old twitter mocks
trudeau and gives a shout out to the
babylon b
and
this
i was watching this clip from bill maher
when he was talking about elon musk and
the purchasing and everything and it
made me realize what's happening with
the establishment what's happening with
um you know elon
the older the boomer generation
they consume their news through cable
television
this is why there are so many people who
are like tucker carlson's far right
because they these are older people who
are only getting their news from cnn and
msnbc and then fox news is like the
other side so there's like three
channels
but most of us the people our age are on
twitter or on facebook or on youtube so
we're getting a big spattering of all
this different news but it's coming
really quickly
i saw this
and bill maher his confusion like a
daughtering old man and i was just like
wow you know i think it's fair to say
one day we will all be old and confused
but
he doesn't need to be
so watching this here's what happens
bill maher says
did you hear about this babylon bee
it's christian satire everybody laughs
and then his guest goes oh yeah because
we need that and bill goes well maybe
some people do
i'm not everybody some people do need it
and then i'm watching that on like bill
did you not google search this story
when it happened
are you just now finding out after elon
already bought twitter what the babylon
b is
and i wondered why it is well
cnn won't report on what the babylon b
is no so someone like bill maher who is
a 60 year old boomer who gets his news
from the new york times physical paper
edition and from cable television
he just now found out about the babylon
b it was march 20th elon was like should
we have free speech and stuff like that
that he was he was asking these
questions that the babylon bee was in
the news and we we were all watching in
real time this progress of elon musk
and bill maher one of the most prominent
shows he's confused and just now finding
out he's in a show called real time yeah
he finds out like a month later
i'm not trying to rag on him i think
it's just you got to point out that he's
in a different world who's his boss well
look he's in a different world and now
think about what that means for every
other news story think about what that
means for hunter biden's laptop think
about that means for epstein all of
these boomers
they're they vote and they and they're
like they mostly vote they're like they
vote way more than young people and they
don't know
half of what we know they don't know a
tenth of what we know because we all saw
the epstein's story in real time and
bill maher probably never saw it
i mean i'm i'm being hyperbolic but
vilmar probably sees it a month later
and he's like what's going on with this
and it's like bill that was that was a
month ago
yeah it seems like it's a it's like a
safety mechanism to wait to let the news
out a month later like the hunter biden
laptop thing they wanted to just hold it
for a month granted it was right before
the olympia election yeah yeah that was
how did it work once it's a month late
it's just doesn't have the fire it
doesn't have the heat like the iron's no
longer hot bill maher has called out the
woke he's criticized this stuff the fact
that he's done that i think shows he's
willing to but he's like an old man
who's looking at his phone being like i
can't press the button and it's like
he's just not on these platforms he
works for warner brothers yeah yeah he
even said i've heard him say he's like
you know there's only so much i can
really get away with i have corporate
you know my
corporation was my check sure sure but
if he's talking about the babylon being
now he could have talked about the
babylon be a month ago in the story bro
was he talking about the rachel levine
thing like in them
he's talking about how
babylon b
made a satirical video about twitter
employees
be freaking out and it's actually really
funny the uh the twitter health expert
yeah he's like he's got a rorschach test
like what do you see she's like nazis
nazis hitler nazis that looks like lips
i hope people don't think that guy works
for twitter too but
it's really funny because uh the bit was
really good she's he's like tell me do
you see elon here now and she's like she
looks at a tennis ball it's got elon's
face she looks at like an employee
pamphlet on the wall and it's got it's
elon on it it was actually really funny
but bill maher was mentioning that
twitter flagged it as sensitive content
and he was like it's a satirical video
mocking you for being too sensitive and
you flagged it as sensitive material
i'm just look that's fine he's speaking
up he's calling it out but why a month
late the point is
i think bill's a good dude i think you
know to a certain extent he's trying but
if the boomer generation isn't paying
attention because we had richie
mcguinness and his mom on and richie's
mom also a boomer didn't know about what
was going on with today's politics the
boomer generation is like i think
they're just totally different realities
for the most part he's incentivized to
not dig too deep like his original show
uh what was it politically incredible
politically incorrect got cancelled he
went hard on 911 and like if he did that
today if he came out it was like let's
talk about the deep state the military
industrial complex they'd be like yeah
warner brothers would be like this is a
little too racy although i think real
time really is just that show renamed
but just a little that's a little like
you remember when uh dennis prager was
on bill maher yeah i think it was like
2017 and he was like the left is lying
there lying and he's like a man cannot
menstruate they're lying and then
everyone laughs yeah everybody like that
bill maher goes wait wait wait what are
you talking about
and uh prager mentions that at
university bathrooms they were putting
tampons in the men's room and bill says
that's for men to bring to their
girlfriends
that one really frustrated me because
the story was actually at that point
like seven years old about bathrooms
with men's rooms with tampons but this
is this is exactly what
what i think we see
i'm not trying to say that every single
boom or anything like that i'm saying on
average if you look at the average age
of a cable tv news viewer it's 62 to 69
or whatever
they're consuming all their news from
the likes of don lemon
no that's not going to work out well for
us yeah also with mars with bill maher's
response that they're just putting them
in there so
guys can get tampons for their
girlfriends or their girlfriend could
just go to the girl's bathroom right
next to it that makes no sense as an
explanation that's like the most
ridiculous i don't want to believe what
i'm being told answer i've ever heard
yeah that's a crazy explanation i think
i think dennis could have been more
prepared but sometimes you're in these
moments and you make a point and you're
not prepared to back it up so when they
were like where what are you talking
about just look it up it's like i could
tell you oh is it september 2016 the
daily beast wrote up that we have to do
it look that up specifically uh side
note the daily beast is now listed as
fake news
i love it look at that
i get this dynamic with comedians
sometimes where they'll be like they'll
say something stupid or irrelevant and
then if you
start to make fun of me like come on it
was a jokey [ __ ] but then if you say
something stupid or irrelevant they're
like you stupid idiot yeah they're like
i know exactly what you mean but they go
like i was just i was just a goof you
know you know what is dangerous for
um
post-liberal whatever this freedom
faction is i don't know they say left
and right and i'm like i don't even know
that that doesn't it doesn't explain
anything to anybody but uh the side that
believes in freedom what's dangerous is
that we see the cnn news stories about
the insurrection and msnbc and rachel
maddow and we all laugh like that's so
dumb no one cares and then you look at
their ratings and you're like cnn and
msnbc get like 400 million combined
views on youtube every month and we get
i think 60.
so
i mean we're doing well but it's mostly
young people these older people are
going to vote and they're going to vote
based on some weird insurrection
narrative
other than voting the people that watch
this show for the most part are
listening to what we're saying the words
very word by word it's all like
registering and they're remembering when
you have these other shows that get
propped up it's like in one ear and out
the other not necessarily every time but
it seems to be and this is also for a
lot of i think your listeners are this
is just a piece to an overall puzzle
they take this piece of information they
take pieces of information from other
places whereas someone on cnn they're
just like i watch cnn they give me my
opinions and those are my opinions and
you know maybe i watch msnbc but like
for the most part they're not kind of
like going and sourcing it from
well this is yeah this is one of the
things that richie's mom was bringing up
she was saying that there used to only
be like three networks and you trusted
them and they said things in a very kind
of reassuring way and you felt confident
in what they were telling you and i
think a lot of that has carried over for
boomers which has turned into a huge
problem because they can just now tell
them whatever they want to and they'll
just believe it like it's a little
unsettling i was talking to my mom about
some awesome stuff about this like just
cool like let's talk about conspiracy
she was like ian man if i was 20 i'd be
i'd be okay i'd be into it but i just
it's just i'm i'm i'm done i'm ready to
i finally got my mom to go on twitter
actually i convinced her how would you
do that to her
well because i kept saying because she
would she's like you know the classic do
you get the emails from like you ever
get my mom just sends me emails of these
oh yeah
you know this um interesting and i was
like yeah i read this on twitter like a
week and a half ago yeah this is you
know but that's new to her because
that's like the the delay on the cycle
that's what bill maher's doing kind of
yeah what kind of is and i go you need
to go on twitter
just and you can you know cut out this
delay and get the news off the source
far superior way to get the news
absolutely
let me give a shout out to michael malus
here he's got a suite he says the
ministry of truth demonstrates the
growing inability of the cathedral to
persuade and an increasing need to just
explicitly tell people what to believe
people have gone from arguing to either
ignoring or presuming not incorrectly
that it's all disingenuous propaganda at
best
we're at the point now
where i think on both sides people are
just absolutely unwilling to hear what
the other point is being made at all
and my view of
what is colloquially colloquially
referred to as the right which is this
large faction of mostly like some kind
of libertarian
is that they want proof they want
sources back up your source back up your
claim not all of them there's there's a
a group of trump supporters who believe
absolutely insane things and you can see
him out there at the rallies with
trump's gonna be president on this day
or whatever it never happens
but next time it will but sure yeah but
i think that's the the exception not the
rule on the left it's the inverse the
average person on the left believes
every single fake story i'm really
interested we've got some lefties coming
on the show soon that we're booking and
i think it's going to be really
interesting for me to be like hey
trayvon martin's story zimmerman did you
believe that you did okay well nbc
edited the audio to make zimmerman seem
racist and he's hispanic how about uh
covington kids did you believe that well
we learned that was fake news justice
millet all these people came out and
supported them that was fake news russia
gave fake news ukraine gate fake news
how many uh ghost of kiev isn't that
black fake news are they doing that
again
it was fake [ __ ] admitted
so my point is now that the ministry of
truth is out and about they're like oh
we gotta play it close here this is the
only thing i can surmise when when the
washington post says
or the media matter smears the whole
show for something like you know sheamus
says my opinion as right wing or far
right or grifting i'm like i guess the
only thing that defines what it is to be
left or right is do you fall for bullish
or do you wait for evidence yeah thomas
massey pointed out that congress
basically split between the the int like
the logical people and the emotional
people and a lot of them are leading
with emotion but either extreme is
dangerous like too much emotion you
don't care about the facts it's just you
get your and then too much logic you
don't care about how people feel you
might end up you know experimenting on
human bodies to get your so you gotta
that's what that's what so right we've
seen societies that are only driven by
logic and they put people's arms into
sub-zero temperatures to watch them
freeze while still attached to their
bodies you know and i will i want to
give a shout out though to all of the
media outlets that were trying to smear
me for defending kyle rittenhouse
prove my point i was right yeah it
wasn't about being conservative or
liberal it was like hey i watched a
video and here's what really happened
kyle was defending himself then they all
come out and they scream the far right
because they're lying nonstop then it
turns out to be correct so i'm really
fascinated this is what the left and the
right is
name a left-wing political position
irrelevant i can sit here all day and we
can talk about taxation and you know
social policy or whatever but the real
question is which stories did you fall
for
if you don't fall for the lies you're
right-wing yeah well in you're correct
that their positions are irrelevant in
many ways and even they will acknowledge
this so on the one hand whenever anyone
points out there's a problem with the
far left their response is oh why
because we want free health care like
what does the far left even mean and
then someone like tim comes out and says
hey i'm actually in favor of free health
care as well but they still call you
fall right
far right because you don't fall for the
same stories they do that's the weirdest
thing what is what is right and left
yeah what do you think of it so there's
this disinformation governance board i
don't know if you guys talked about this
but what happens when
the next president is trump or desantis
and he goes okay we have this
disinformation governance board
she's out my guy's in
but what's insane no no no no i i i
think if it's trump or desantis they
might just dissolve it instantly well
they might but i'm saying i'm just
saying hypothetically mitt romney if it
was mitt romney somehow gets elected
yeah then he's gonna be like it's time
to uh put on a new guy who's gonna talk
about what's the real truth if it's the
sanders or trump trump's gonna be like
i'm getting rid of it it's wrong but
imagine the hysterics if he goes yeah
you guys great idea everyone last
administration i love this idea here's
my guy but yeah that that was true back
when the establishment were playing a
game of hot potato when it was like john
mccain versus obama it was just chill
establishment didn't matter who came
into power you know george w bush comes
in with all these wars and barack obama
was like we're going to change it then
gets in it's like i'm going to kill kids
instead then barack obama signs the
indefinite detention provisions then
barack obama increases the drone attacks
and you know that if a republican like
mitt romney were to win it wouldn't
matter
but then trump won and he broke these
people yeah so we were sort of talking
about that the other day and
i don't think that's an effective thing
to say to left-wingers unfortunately
because they know that while
right-wingers could use that power to be
authoritarian and suppress them that
they actually need that power in order
to survive because in order for like
left-wing orthodoxy to flourish you
basically have to scare people into
pretending to believe something else
because no one's gonna like voluntarily
agree to the idea that children should
change their genders not in the number
that people are giving a sent to it now
well this is this is the crazy thing
that
two things occur when i made a point on
twitter i said it's crazy that if you
believe children shouldn't be getting
sex change surgery you're considered
right wing two things happen one i got
called a transphobe and two people were
like that's not happening you're lying
the left isn't doing that and the
response to every single person who says
that is someone showing a news story
talking about medical intervention
chemical or or surgical
and it's literally happening so either
you're a lying grifter who's pushing
right wing talking points to your right
wing or you're a transphobe to your
right wing and i'm like dude okay
whatever i guess right the the um
the quintessential left wing position
that's not happening but it's good that
it's happening you're bad for opposing
it i don't think it's transphobic to to
care about to protect children from you
know gender surgery sexual surgeries at
that point you know being transphobic is
like meeting someone that's an adult
person that's trans and being like i
don't want to be anywhere near that
person or i'm going to talk crap about
them thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you